[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist got
with me chuck nice co-host hey what's
all right
today we're gonna do some explaining
let's explaining front to back right
three seconds
that's become its own genre yeah it is
every time you say we're gonna do
something explaining i i almost want to
look over my shoulder for my wife
because
because of i love lucy uh well yeah
exactly that's what i'm normally that's
where it normally you know okay
so this i guess
i don't know if we settled on a title
it's it's stuff you thought you knew
okay i like it even stuff you never knew
that you didn't know so oh
i like that
as a title too
yeah yeah you never knew that you never
knew yeah and you never knew you never
knew three segments we're going to talk
about
what we really mean by temperature
okay
second
we're talking about
size and wavelength
right on there's stuff happening there
you i don't think you knew that you knew
or didn't know that you didn't know and
well if we're talking about that i know
i didn't know okay
all right
and it'll make you look twice at your
microwave oven make sure it's designed
properly
and third we're going to talk about
horsepower
and how completely irrelevant it is
when applied to rocket engines
as nasa has done for decades
so that's on this edition on star talk
stuff you thought you knew
so
i we've talked a little bit about
temperature before
yes but i i just want to just sort of do
it again
but all right i think the you know 10
minutes just isn't enough time to say
everything you need to say
about temperature we're still talking
about temperature that's correct okay
correct so let me first tell you
in the world of physics what temperature
is okay oh okay
temperature only has meaning
when you have an ensemble of particles
that are vibrating
okay okay okay
so
okay
uh how fast is everything
vibrating
okay
and
you get oh how fast is this one and this
one and all sort of moving in
in different directions like the
molecules in a gas cloud or even even in
a solid object the particles are
vibrating right and you can ask what is
the average kinetic energy energy of
this motion of all those particles so
okay let me just ask then
do those vibrations from these particles
produce
some type of measurable energy like heat
yeah so they bang up against your
thermometer
and then the thermometer gives you a
reading oh
that is
that's kind of dope i'm liking it so far
that's okay so we're clean on that right
yes yeah no problem okay
so
what happens if you don't have any
particles
um
you should be really chilly
like
you need a glass of you need a cup of
tea it means you're chilling yeah
yeah no how do you measure the
temperature of something
if you don't have a vibration particles
vibrating against it so what happens in
that case is
because the vibrating molecules or
particles are not the only thing that
can put energy to your thermometer okay
okay
all right
light can do the same thing too or
electromagnetic energy which includes
light right
visible light so
light
goes to your thermometer as well all
right
but your thermometer has to be able to
absorb it
in order to then get a temperature for
you okay all right if you're trying to
find the temperature of the visible
light in this room
and your thermometer is made of
transparent glass the visible light goes
right through the glass and you won't
get the temperature of that light
okay so
so it's
temperature is not
a completely obvious thing
under certain circumstances that are
that are not even much of a stretch
okay so i'll give you another example i
once calculated
dare i say famously calculated
how long it would take to cook a
16 inch pepperoni pizza pepperoni pizza
on the windowsill of your home on the
planet venus okay is this gluten free
we're talking no
[Laughter]
and did you make that calculation
i didn't do the gluten factor okay the
gluten correction i didn't make right so
here's what happens the atmosphere in
venus has like a hundred times
as many particles in it per volume so
it's a hundred times as dense
so so there you have it your pizza in
the oven and there's hot air hitting it
but i have a hundred times as much hot
air hitting it
okay olive venus is one big convection
pizza pizza oven right so there it is
all right but
and the air is hotter
okay the air is like 900 degrees
fahrenheit so
so and a pizza oven's only around 500
degrees fahrenheit so
so what you have a hundred times the
atmospheric
uh contact
and 500 more fahrenheit degrees
uh to boot so i calculate if it takes 15
minutes to cook a pizza and you do the
fractions and you do this right i did it
i got about seven seconds between seven
and nine so
to cook a pepperoni pizza well no and
and will be there in 30 minutes or less
guaranteed baby
guaranteed
well yeah there's a two it's seven and
nine seconds around there so then as
i've told you before
the geek spectrum
knows no limits
and who's and who occupies it all right
as i say that all the time when our good
friend charles chelsea was born right so
i put this out there and i and somebody
called me out and said dr tyson
you neglected the radiant energy
just from the gas being hot
that's in addition
to the molecular contact energy that's
going on at the pizza surface
if you included that
the pizza gets cooked in like two or
three seconds
right
not the seven seconds so it's not only
the transfer of heat from the vibrating
molecules there's the
infrared light
that's coming out of the warm oven not
only the air itself but the walls of the
cavity that's why pizza ovens are brick
ovens because the ideal one's because
the oven is radiating to the pizza right
top of the air yeah everything around it
is hot not everything around it is hot
so it's it's it so the pizza is lose is
is is gaining
energy
from the air molecules
directly and from the walls of the oven
indirectly because of the radiant um
influx of infrared in that case okay so
there's these two ways so if you have a
thermometer in the vacuum of space right
what matters is how much of the photons
of light is the thermometer absorbing
so if you wrap the thermometer in
reflective mylar
then the temperature will just keep
dropping
until it reaches the temperature of the
whole universe which is damn near
zero degrees
kelvins
absolute zero
so
the temperature has to do with what are
you wearing
wait a minute we've heard this i'm sorry
i i thought we were doing that thing
well you know chuck what are you wearing
what are you wearing
no nose who are you wearing chuck yeah
right oh yeah yeah that's the red carpet
way did you wear it well so
when they say
wear lighter clothes in the summer right
what they're saying is the air will have
whatever temperature it does
but you don't wanna and it's going to be
hot probably but you don't want to add
to that by absorbing light from the sun
because that will just add more
temperature
that's why in the summer time i just
wear bike reflectors
if you do that i didn't walk around with
bike reflectors on that's all you'll get
if if so if you just clad your body with
bike bicycle reflectors or something
that is good at reflecting sunlight
which could just be
by the way it's been rumored that you
know all futuristic sci-fi
um
space things that people wear they're
always reflective you have a silver
they're always silver it could be
because they're living too close to
their host star
and they have to keep reflecting it off
to stay cool
point is you cannot speak
singularly about the temperature of the
air in any way that matters to you
if you're also exposed to
light
that could be absorbed
by what you're wearing
so in the winter
it's cold out you want as much extra
energy as you can get so where dark
clothes the dark clothes absorb sunlight
and then the temperature inside your
clothes goes higher than would otherwise
be if it was just if you were just
measuring the air
right
that's that is why
in the winter time i hang out with my
black friends and in the summertime i
hang out with my white friends
and i'm always
that's the right temperature i'm in the
goldilocks spot always
and in the fall and winter you say oh
can you back up a little come a little
no you move away exactly
in the fall and spring i just hang out
with puerto ricans
damn trucker's gonna get this show
cancelled
come on people y'all can't get mad at
that
come on that was pretty funny yeah
so i'm just saying temperature is just a
little more complicated than you might
otherwise think right that's all it's
not just
what is the air it's how fast are your
molecules vibrating and what is causing
that to vibrate and the air is how we
usually think about it but other things
can make that happen as well
so that that's what i'm saying and there
are rules about
the thermometer that gives you the
official weather weather service
temperature
that thermometer is in a shadow it's not
open to the sunlight ah
okay in fact i i used to do this when i
was growing up i think they've corrected
this so the bank
temperature time signs you know they
used to be on all remember time and
temperature time and temperature right i
would look at bank time and temperatures
that were in sunlight
and bank time and temperatures that were
in shade
and the official air temperature might
be 90 degrees the bank's thermometer
would say 105 degrees it's like no it's
not okay because you're sitting out in
the sunlight right and you're absorbing
the sun on top of the air temperature so
that
misrepresents what you would feel
standing in the air but in shadow
in the shadow of a tree for example
and when you walk under a tree say oh
it's cooler under the tree
the air is the same temperature so chuck
why is it cooler under the tree well the
absolute same as the shadow temperature
it's the absence of the light
being directly on you it's the absence
of the light that you would be absorbing
that would make you feel hotter it's not
just a feeling you're actually hotter
than the air temperature when you're
absorbing the sunlight wow
there you go that's pretty cool man yeah
so that's just so temperature i could go
on and on there's a lot more to
temperature than just a reading that's
correct correct and one thing i've said
in multiple shows and i'll say it again
the fact that you can see the sun in the
daytime
all right that's an obvious fact right
means the sunlight is
moving through the atmosphere and the
atmosphere is transparent to sunlight
okay
it's a visible light at least
so
and the visible light is where the sun's
energy peaks
so if the atmosphere is transparent to
the sun
the sun is not heating the air
because the energy is going straight
through it right oh man i mean well
there you go okay wait wait it's so wet
okay so then then what does it finally
hit at the ground the ground and then
the ground warms up and then the ground
is in physical contact with the air and
the ground heats the air
so chuck holding aside an exotic upper
layer of the atmosphere what i'm
generally telling you is what is the
hottest part of the earth's atmosphere
uh right next to the ground right next
to the ground and as you ascend the
temperature drops as we all know if you
paid any attention at all to the data on
the screen in an airplane and what's the
temperature outside the airplane 40
below zero right
so icarus had it all wrong
he didn't fly too close to the right his
wings would have froze
they they knew nothing about
thermodynamics right when they invented
the story of icarus that's pretty good
as he ascends to get close to the sun he
would have been farther away from the
sun's source of heat on earth
and the temperature would have dropped
and dropped and his wings would have
frozen and cracked he still would have
fallen
but for different reasons okay
all right chuck we gotta call it quits
there that's very cool i'm so uh yeah
who knew that was you always surprised
me man you always surprised me that's
the whole point of this i guess i could
yeah i didn't think we could get this
much out of temperature
temperatures a lot going on i didn't who
knew there was this was going on with
temperature and let me just say if you
go high enough in the atmosphere you
reach the ozone layer
right what what does the ozone do oh it
protects us from radiation and and yeah
from harmful rays
rays of the sun okay so to protect us it
means it absorbs it
nice okay so tell me about the
temperature of the ozone layer
yes
it must be really hot it gets hot and so
in fact if you look at the temperature
profile of our atmosphere the
temperature drops
until you get to what we call the
thermosphere and the temperature goes
back up
because in that layer
the chemistry of the atmosphere is
absorbing ultraviolet rays from the sun
and that heats that layer
and protects us down here on the surface
that's very cool there you go there you
go all right
well the only thing i really took away
from this whole thing is that on venus
no one ever says who touched the
thermostat
[Laughter]
plus delivered in 30 minutes or less
is way too long if they don't cook your
pizza in four seconds
nice all right we gotta take a quick
break but when we come back
we're gonna talk about
size and wavelength
okay these are two things you don't
normally hear in the same sentence this
is true we're gonna put them together in
ways that maybe you'd never thought of
before
welcome back to star talk things you
thought you knew
chuck you may have heard of
the wave particle duality yes
light
yeah is it a wave or is it a particle
and
hey
you got waving my particle hey you got
particles in my wave
if you're over 60 you'll get that
reference to a tv commercial
for reese's reese's peanut butter this
is peanut butter so the problem is we
have a brain that wants to
compartmentalize okay and doesn't really
blend to
what feels like disparate bits of
information so people tried they
invented the word ravicle i thought that
was pretty cool never caught on lavacal
have you ever heard ravicle yeah because
yeah it doesn't work that's why it
doesn't work but let me just give some
uh
interesting examples
it actually sounds like
uh something the professor from the
simpsons whoever call you know hawaiian
play
i'm sorry
all right
so
uh before we pick up wavicle let me just
remind you that light
which in my field we call the
electromagnetic
spectrum
okay
is all forms of light
most familiar to us is visible light
okay red orange yellow green blue violet
okay but if you go on the other side of
red
you get to what
um
infrared infrared very nice the ah your
retina can't detect it but it exists
right they do have infrared sensors it's
we detect it on our skin as heat
all right so we can detect infrared but
not we don't see it we feel it though
that by the way
makes us sound so much cooler than we
really are oh without with our skin
sensors we've got infrared sensors yes
yes yes yes yes okay now uh you go
beyond the violet you get what
ultraviolet ultraviolet so that's beyond
the violet we can't see ultraviolet
either
we also have sensors
for ultraviolet but they're
significantly time delayed oh i thought
you meant like black lights that just
show us all the nastiness that happened
in a hotel oh no no that no what happens
in in the in under quote black light is
you're you're illuminating the crime
scene with
ultraviolet light which you cannot see
and certain substances fluoresce under
it and send you the light back
in violet light that you can
never seeing the ultraviolet you're
never seeing the ultraviolet no no no no
no no no okay so
so here we are on ultraviolet we have
ultraviolet sensors they're just time
delayed
okay okay so the time delay is okay
you're out in the sun
oh and an hour later you feel like you
have your sun if you have lighter
colored skin you're you feel like you're
you get sunburned
and you do that enough then you get skin
cancer these are in a way detectors of
ultraviolet it's just too late right
okay right let's go back to the other
end uh so we had red infrared and you
keep going in that direction on this
spectrum by the way what's changing on
the spectrum is the wavelength of the
light
okay so as we go to the red wavelengths
are getting bigger and bigger we get to
ultra we get to infrared beyond
infrared we get to microwaves micro yeah
okay so now i can describe the length of
the wave like with physical fingers and
things so a
microwave is like a few millimeters to
like
maybe a couple of centimeters around wow
let's just call it a centimeter yeah a
physical centimeter that's
that's a pretty big weight that's a big
wave that's a half an inch and so a full
wave a crest and a trough gets
manifested in that space when you have
microwaves okay nice okay let's go
beyond that you get to what we call
radio waves right
so
[Music]
before microwaves had their own name
they would just short wavelength radio
waves
okay
okay so then we said well there's small
versions of radio waves let's call them
microwaves and that's why they have
they're called micro
even though they're bigger than infrared
right all right that's all i'm saying
here okay
so so radio waves are like meters
and longer we don't have word
a radio wave can be miles in wavelength
we don't have a different word for that
so
radio waves are for everything bigger
than microwaves
all right so now watch
if i want to detect a radio wave
i need a thing
that's at least as big as one of the
waves
gotcha
so
tv
old world tv
before it came in via cable
used antennae
how long was a tv antenna
um two stories huh
the one on your tv
exactly was about a meter long right
yeah okay in fact you'd have two of them
sticking out all over the place and
you'd extend it to about the length of
the waves of the of the radio waves
you're trying to receive
okay
all i'm saying is you can't detect
waves bigger than the size of your
detector it doesn't work okay okay it'll
just wash over your detector your
detector won't even know what happened
right so how about microwaves have you
ever seen a microwave
walkie-talkies
how long is the antenna on our microwave
walkie-talkie
you know it's about like that there's
nothing to it it's about it's about it's
like an inch and a half
there's your microwaves
that's the size of the microwaves that's
pretty wild
that's that's so it it is the size to
fit the situation
right okay that also means
if you have a substance that prevents
the transmission
of any of this energy okay you could put
holes in it and as long as the holes are
smaller than the wave the wave is not
going to get through
whoa
that
is that the like
so take a look at your microwave oven
that's what i was about to say that's
right so the blackways so white
microwaves go through glass no problem
gotcha all right so
but you so you have a glass thing so
microwaves and visible light go through
you can see your food cooking but
there's something else on the other side
there's a screen screen
and that screen is opaque to microwaves
okay
except they put holes in it
now that's why i got this tumor on my
head you know what you stopped
don't stick your head inside the
microwave
so
so
neither you nor the microwaves can see
through that material except for the
fact that they put holes in the material
right how big are the holes
tiny they're smaller than the size of
the microwaves they're using in that
oven that's pretty wild microwaves
cannot it's the antenna in reverse in
reverse oh i like that very clever
very clever
so
so
so you can put holes in things so radio
telescopes
have you ever seen a radio telescope go
to a radio telescope one day the bit the
big they're huge
they're huge and they're made of like
mesh
they're like chicken wire mesh
with these huge holes in it because it's
depending on which
kind of radio telescope you're visiting
that the the the metal is reflective of
radio waves but you don't have to build
the whole surface of of metal you can
put big holes in it makes it lighter all
right and rain can get through and not a
problem and with because of these huge
dishes and they can take radio waves
reflect them to a focus and there you
have it
that is uh really really cool well let's
keep going in the other direction okay
okay there's more
but wait there's more okay i was
satisfied but yes all right please
continue let's go let's go the other
direction so we go red orange yellow
green blue violet ultraviolet you go be
honest with you you have x-rays x-rays
wavelengths are getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller okay
really tiny tiny tiny tiny
much smaller than the wavelengths for
visible light
all right so now watch
if i have a regular microscope
and i want to see something small
i cannot see anything smaller
than the wavelength
of the violet light i'm using in the
visible spectrum
oh man because otherwise it washes right
over it would not even know it's there
right
okay
so if you want to see things smaller
then the wavelength of visible light
that would be the violet side of it you
need even smaller wavelengths of light
interesting
so so here's talk about getting clever
you ready
so people
said how about electrons
right you say well electrons are
particles they're not waves they're also
waves oh my gosh what wavelength
corresponds to electrons that we could
generate in the machine
x-rays
oh my gosh
so electrons and x-rays have the same
wavelength wow
so if i invent a microscope that uses
electrons
then i'm using a wavelength of light
as small
as
x-rays so i can see the tiniest detail
so the photographs that have this the
most exquisite detail of the smallest
things are not regular microscope
photographs they're electron microscopes
because we we
we
what do you call it we co-opted we
commandeered electrons
piggybacked an electron
using the
x-ray wavelength that it represents
to take that's where you see those bug
pictures with the hairs and right things
yeah and and
and the um and the the bacteria all this
there you go
that is
fascinating
that that's that's that and that's how
electron microscopes work that's how
they work isn't it clever of the human
mind to do that after quantum physics we
said we got the wave particle duality
and i can't see anything smaller than
the wavelength of violet light but i
know there's got to be detail there
because there's detail up until the
point where it gets fuzzy right well let
me keep going and then you invent the
electron microscope and bada bing
the world of of the small continues to
open to you so that means if so is our
gam what's the smallest wave is it gamma
yeah so the smallest uh waves that we
have a word for are gamma rays so gamma
rays are like are the opposite
like radio waves so it's smaller
wavelengths than x-rays or gamma rays
and then we don't have it we don't keep
dividing it so
so gamma rays that are like really
really really small they're still
they're still called gamma rays yes okay
so the problem is if you a gamma ray
telescope you have to be able to focus
it
okay it's not good enough just to use
the light yeah you need to be clever
about with the machine you're making and
we know how to focus electrons because
they have a charge and so we can focus
them down and get images and things so
yeah
so the only thing uh gamma rays are good
for is making you a superhero hulk yeah
yeah that's that's tested we we know
right we know that
and i think it's gamma rays on the on
spider-man too
if um i don't know i'm not sure what it
is it was a radioactive spider it was a
radioactive spider that bit him
and i don't i'm not sure what ra what
what what kind of machine
was using to make him
you know
first of all i just love that we went
from pure science here's how an electron
microscope works too
now exactly uh how the spiderman
and this is how you become the hulk
how you becoming
so all i'm saying is check your
microwave oven if your holes are the
size of like a centimeter they're too
big and microwaves are leaking out
right if they're down around a
millimeter or two then that's a good
size you're not getting the mic the
microwaves are not getting out there you
go there you go you don't want to end up
with a tumor on your head like chuck
nice see what do you do what what why
are you white that tmi
so what's going on on your forehead oh
no now i had a concussion some time ago
and this i have to get this surgically
removed so it's it's there now and it
won't go away
okay all right and my wife did it
i may have buried the lead but
it's all right so that's a little bit um
on size and wavelengths that you might
not have known
a connection that you might not have
known was ever there that was great all
right chuck we got to take a quick break
but when can't come back
all kinds of stuff you never knew about
horsepower
oh nice in our third segment when we
return
we're back star talk things you thought
you knew our third and final segment
all about horsepower chuck i do a lot of
a fair amount of reading of history i
love
looking at how we used to think about
things and how the advance of science
and technology
modifies improves supplants
whole words whole concepts that
just become obsolete
yeah like i think our parents might have
been the generation that might have
still called a refrigerator and icebox
which because it was an actual icebox
literal icebox
you know the iceman would come in fact
my mother gets the ice here
nice cold ice
is how cold it is it's ice cold
and so chuck uh where was the
the
space within the box where they put the
ice
uh hopefully up top since cold air falls
exactly cold air fall chuck you you're
thermodynamically fluent i love you man
okay and it would have a mechanism where
it melted and you'd replace the pan at
the bottom with where the water melted
okay
so
then we have then we don't need ice for
it anymore because we perfect
refrigerators and it orphans some
people's vocabulary
and but that's fine i don't think anyone
under 60 calls it an ice box anymore so
i i'm i
i find that fun to track yeah vocabulary
the evolution of vocabulary in the face
of the progress of science and
technology you just reminded me of my
great grandmother and i'm just having a
fond memory right now because she lived
until i was
30
and she was born
in 1901
[Music]
and used to routinely tell me about
the iceman and the fishmonger
and the
milk man
that all these people came around and by
the way
on horse-drawn carriage
so that's the stuff you didn't get from
the market right somebody came by and
you got it outside your door especially
since it was perishable or it would melt
right exactly they couldn't just leave
it at the market hoping you'd come by
and get it right exactly right so
so we go from horses
which
you know we built civilization on the
back of horses we also fought wars on
the backs of horses and they never got a
thank you they never got it
no there's some horse memorials in the
world get out the to the war horses yes
i was speaking with my sister about that
also many a war statue are the soldiers
on a horse so
um this is the horses are a fundamental
part of that but you're right i don't
think anyone told the horses before they
went to the battle that they'd be shot
at i'm pretty sure that was not a
they did not buck every soldier
so we use horses up until
like the car is invented right right so
um uh carl benz
sort of makes a really good version of
an internal combustion engine and
and we're off to the races
uh so so then what happens to the horse
well the horse rapidly disappears
especially from urban centers and then
basically from all of civilization much
later on farms i think but eventually
they would be replaced with tractors
okay
so
what is the power of a horse
well i don't know but let's just call it
one horsepower okay
so now you have a
car
and what is someone who rode horses all
their life call a car
a horse-drawn carriage without a horse
a horseless carriage a horseless
carriage okay
because that's the reference frame
you're using to identify so now you say
how powerful is the engine
we don't have any way to think about the
power of the engine other than in
reference to
horses so car engines started getting
measured in horsepower that makes sense
horsepower
okay so one horsepower so i know that's
like what like my horse right two
horsepower hey oh i got a pretty nice
carrots going on yeah you got carriage
going off yeah horsepower oh four horses
this is like cinderella no and six
horsepower is ben hur yeah
okay
so
so so there you have it now so power
once we all became metrified
uh you can think of it in terms of watts
so
uh one horsepower
uh equals about
750 watts
okay
all right and because power doesn't have
to be how fast you're moving it's what
is your the rate that you are consuming
energy so
in the old days hair dryers would be up
around that many watts right now and
they put it
they put it on a hair dryer still oh
well no watch they don't put horsepower
on here no the watts yeah yes definitely
put watts on it yeah but i'm saying but
generally you see horsepower on on
things like that go into motion or in
some cases i've seen
horsepower on on lawn mowers
on
motorcycles yes things that have sort of
engines because that's where the deepest
routes are traceable to when horses did
that work
that's all i'm saying okay so now
we are left with the completely absurd
completely
absurd statement
in nasa press releases
of how many horsepower
the shuttle rocket engines are oh man i
love that okay
oh man it's like souped up santa claus
2 000 horses flying into the sky
so you have nasa's press releases saying
the shuttle main engine produces 37
million horsepower oh my god
okay okay that's like that and so you
say that's powerful but
it is completely meaningless right
because because there are not 37 million
horses
anywhere
you will not find 37 million horses
probably on earth
so let alone all together just hanging
out
at kennedy space center right exactly so
now let's just say you could strap them
together right
no matter how clever is your strapping
your 37 million horsepower
is not gonna
if it's actually made of horses
it's not going to put you into orbit
right horses are not going to ascend
from earth and go into orbit around
earth however it is kind of cool to
start every space mission with five four
three two
yeah
[Laughter]
gentlemen start your horses exactly
so we we didn't have a term
that comes to us from cars
that we need to then apply to apply to
rockets it would have been nice if we
had car power right right leave horses
behind now we have car so what's car
power let's say 100 horsepower is now
one car power let's say
all right then we could talk about
rockets in car power if we're going to
be one generation behind i would have
been okay with that
but no
they kept referencing horses
which i personally i think is completely
absurd and like i say now since
horsepower is just a matter of power and
so are watts and we all in the usa we're
all watt fluent all right um we could
just use watts kilowatts that sort of
thing
okay there was a similar challenge
when
we detonated the first
atomic bomb
yeah right so is there a unit of
energy to talk about atomic bombs no
because no one ever made one before so
let me guess
we now use
exploding horses
[Laughter]
so so we looked back and said what is
the biggest explosion that we had before
oh dynamite a stick of dynamite okay
and dynamite is tnt
and tnt by the way
discovered by alfred nobel
got quite wealthy on it from it and then
created a fund
to
reward
science and peaceful applications of it
especially with regard to medicine so
so tnt
a stick of tnt dynamite was is the
biggest explosion we had so now we have
an even bigger explosion and so atomic
bombs
were measured with respect to how many
tons of tnt it would be wow okay
so
the two bombs dropped in japan in
warfare
by the united states
each of those was between 10 and 20
kilotons
of tnt
10
10 20 000
kilotons okay that's crazy so now watch
so that's a fission bomb that takes
uranium and plutonium big atoms splits
them into two lighter atoms but they're
they're
those two lighter atoms when you add
them back you don't get to the original
atom there's extra energy that got
converted into the bomb okay that's it
all right so
we would
develop an even more potent nuclear
weapon called the hydrogen bomb
which comes from fusing hydrogen atoms
together to make helium so you take four
hydrogen atoms you get a helium atom and
you have you started out with more mass
than you ended up where did the mass go
became energy energy equals mc squared
all right wow so
mild hydrogen bombs
are a thousand times more powerful than
your atom bombs
wow so we don't speak of them in terms
of kilotons we speak of them in terms of
megatons
nice 10 megatons 50 megatons mega as in
as in million right okay
so once again we have these
devastatingly powerful weapons
uh and we're referencing their power
by something alfred nobel invented a
century earlier
wow
and so to me that's the same as well i
mean not identically the same but it's
it's it's linguistically the same as
calling a refrigerator in an ice box
right talking about the power of your
car in horsepower right right and we're
still there it's still measured in
megaton it's still measuring megaton is
there anything bigger than a hydrogen
bomb
um
not that well a supernova
is is pretty big but we just measure
those in in ergs with a power very high
power yeah we stop finding words for it
we just let's just go back to any any
unit of energy and stick in like and
stick it there stick it there
right we're not we're not we're not
measuring supernova in terms of
horsepower
or
tnt right right right this is not this
is not happening
you know what would be good
if we measured it this would blend pop
culture with science if we measured it
in
death star power
yes the power it takes to completely
obliterate a planet
we can calculate what that is oh my god
and then our hydrogen bombs would be
it's only one millionth a death star
right that's pretty cool but then it
becomes small rather than large exactly
yeah but yeah you can calculate exactly
how much energy it takes to completely
obliterate a planet right and by the way
in star wars the force awakens where
they have the new and improved death
star they can kill all the planets of
the entire solar system right and you
know where it got its energy from
where
okay it sucks the energy out of a nearby
star oh the star okay so it goes to a
star sucks out all the energy contains
it and then
dishes it out and take out a whole solar
system all at once so that's badass
right that is pretty badass except if
you actually add up all the energy of a
star
it could kill a thousand planets not
just 10 minutes oh wow they didn't do
their math because they really think
then the the dark force the dark side
would have been way more powerful than
anything portrayed in that movie
you know what we should do a show and i
don't want to offend anybody because i'm
a huge star wars fan
but
over the years i've heard you say many
many things
star wars gets hold back that they get
it and that they get totally wrong we
should do a show called star wars is
no stupid we said it'd be awesome
i mean it doesn't mean that we don't
like it it just means like look here's
all the bad science that you find in
star wars i mean like like
there's a smooth rolling
metal spherical ball right and somehow
it's not sliding uncontrollably on sand
um not only sand but on wax floors like
a bowling ball
dude that'll be a great show star wars
is stupid look okay
how to cut your viewership in half
all right so there you have it just sort
of orphaned vocabulary yes as time moves
on
and yeah it's just how culture embraces
it or not so chuck we gotta land this
plane oh man or land those horses uh yes
i was gonna say oh are we do we have
saddles do we have saddles to lie in
this place we're going to uh
cut the red wire on the fuse to that
bomb right and bring this this uh this
episode to a close but i enjoyed it i
enjoyed talking about stuff that yeah
people don't always know that they know
these are fun
yeah yeah and i i'd like i'd like to
believe it it connects you just a little
more closely
to the coming and going
of society and all the ways that
technology touches it or doesn't
i love that
you know all right this has been star
talk always good to have you chuck
always a pleasure neil degrasse tyson
here
keep looking up
[Music]
you